From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Love, love, love, love. Love.
爱，爱，爱，爱。爱。
What do we talk about when we talk about love? Well, since the 13th century, this is what we talk about, this very moment.
当我们谈论爱时，我们在谈论什么？好吧，自13世纪以来，我们谈论的就是这个，就在此刻。
A coup de foudre. Coup de foudre, in French, means a bolt of lightning. Seeing someone and in an instant, you've fallen in love. Love which happens in a moment of a flash.
一见钟情（Coup de foudre）。在法语中，“Coup de foudre”的意思是闪电击中。看到某人，瞬间便坠入爱河。爱发生在电光火石的一瞬间。
This is Richard Klein of Cornell University. In the 13th century, he says, Petrarch was walking by a fountain in the south of France. Turns a corner, sees Laura. Petrarch looks into her eyes and in an instant, his life is transformed. And he writes the first lyric love poems ever written.
这是康奈尔大学的理查德·克莱因。他说，在13世纪，彼特拉克走在法国南部的一个喷泉边。转过弯，看到了劳拉。彼特拉克看着她的眼睛，瞬间，他的人生被改变了。他写下了有史以来第一批抒情爱情诗。
He says before this moment, one lives in a state of distraction. And things come and go, experiences fragmentary and chaotic. And all of a sudden, at the moment in which you encounter the eye of the other, it turns you into something else. Suddenly you become-- your whole being becomes focused on that experience. And all you want to do, once you've had that experience, is to return over and over to that.
他说，在此刻之前，人处于一种心不在焉的状态。事情来来去去，经历碎片化且混乱。突然之间，在你与对方目光交汇的瞬间，它把你变成了另一个人。刹那间你变得——你的整个生命都聚焦于那种体验。而一旦你有了那种体验，你所想做的，就是一次又一次地回到那种体验中去。
30 years later, in Florence, Dante goes through the same thing when he sees, at the top of a flight of stairs, Beatrice. He writes about it. And the idea of this moment, the bolt of lightning, gets repeated in literature and song and theater all through the Renaissance, up through the 19th century, and into the present day, today. People who have not experienced that bolt of lightning in years. People who have been married for decades go to the movies, watch TV, to see it reenacted over and over. This is what we talk about, when we talk about love.
30年后，在佛罗伦萨，但丁在楼梯顶端看到贝阿特丽采时，经历了同样的事情。他写下了它。关于这一瞬间的想法——那道闪电，在文艺复兴时期、19世纪一直到今天，都在文学、歌曲和戏剧中被反复重现。那些多年未曾经历过那道闪电的人，结婚几十年的夫妻，依然会去看电影、看电视，一遍又一遍地观看它的重演。这就是当我们谈论爱时，我们所谈论的东西。
In ancient Greek, the Greeks had two verbs for seeing. [SPEAKING GREEK] and [SPEAKING GREEK]. [SPEAKING GREEK] is a way of seeing what we ordinarily understand as observation. [SPEAKING GREEK] refers to the look that eyes can flash, like lightning, like dragon breath, that not only illuminates the eye, but sends out a kind of fire that penetrates the eye of the other.
在古希腊语中，希腊人有两个表示“看”的动词。[希腊语发言]和[希腊语发言]。[希腊语发言]是一种我们通常理解的观察方式。[希腊语发言]指的是眼睛能闪烁出的光芒，像闪电，像龙息，不仅照亮了眼睛，还射出一种能穿透对方眼眸的火焰。
And they had specifically a separate word for that.
他们专门有一个单独的词来形容那个。
That's right, for the moment when the eyes flash. And flash in a way which implies some kind of fateful encounter.
没错，就是指眼睛闪烁的那一刻。那种闪烁暗示着某种宿命般的邂逅。
I was struck looking at those tapes of Monica Lewinsky embracing the president on those rope lines. The thing that's most compelling about those images is the way her eyes flash at him. One can't help but be struck by the light that's coming from those eyes.
看到那些莫妮卡·莱温斯基在警戒线旁拥抱总统的录像带时，我感到很震撼。这些影像中最引人注目的，是她看向他时眼神闪烁的方式。人们无法不被那双眼睛射出的光芒所打动。
OK, now here's the crazy thing. Everybody knows that that moment of initial rapture, that instant when your eyes meet and you're obsessed with the other person, thinking about them all the time. Everybody knows that that feeling doesn't usually last, that in some way it's just a dream. That over time, it changes into something different. Here's the thing. Even on the day that this romantic myth of love was born, that day in the 13th century when Petrarch saw Laura, even on that day, it was clear that it was just a myth, it was just a dream. Petrarch doesn't get the girl.
好了，现在疯狂的事情来了。每个人都知道，那一刻最初的狂喜，当你目光交汇，对另一个人着迷，无时无刻不在想念他们的那一瞬间。每个人都知道，那种感觉通常不会持续，它在某种程度上只是一个梦。随着时间的推移，它会变成别的东西。问题就在这里。即使在浪漫爱情神话诞生的那天，在13世纪彼特拉克看到劳拉的那一天，即使在那天，也很清楚那只是一个神话，只是一个梦。彼特拉克最终并没有得到那个女孩。
You know, the usual story is that the guy doesn't get the girl. But maybe you never get the girl. Maybe that's the condition of falling in love, that it always remains something sort of inaccessible. The moment that desire is fulfilled, desire dies.
你知道，通常的故事是男孩没得到女孩。但也许你永远得不到那个女孩。也许这就是坠入爱河的本质，它总是保持着某种难以企及的状态。当欲望得到满足的那一刻，欲望也就消亡了。
Psychologists have estimated that you can only stay in love for 18 months. That's the limit. After that, it becomes something else. It becomes admiration, respect, affection, but--
心理学家估计，你只能保持那种恋爱状态18个月。那是极限。在那之后，它变成了别的东西。它变成了钦佩、尊重、温情，但是——
The dream of it dissolves and becomes something else.
爱的幻梦消散了，变成了别的东西。
Something else.
别的东西。
I wonder if you would be saying this and explaining this in these terms if you yourself were falling in love right now.
我想知道，如果你自己现在正坠入爱河，你还会用这些词汇来解释它吗？
Well, as a matter of fact, I think I am.
好吧，事实上，我想我确实是。
Well then, you're going to get in trouble when this goes on the radio, aren't you?
那么，当节目播出时，你会有麻烦的，不是吗？
Oh, I'm going to be in so much trouble, You have no idea.
噢，我会陷入大麻烦的，你简直无法想象。
So you're falling in love right now, and you're holding to the idea that this is an illusion-- a sort of an illusory experience?
所以你现在正坠入爱河，却坚持认为这是一种幻觉——一种虚幻的体验？
Oh, but all I want is more illusion. More illusion.
噢，但我想要的只有更多的幻觉。更多的幻觉。
So today, beloved listener, we come to you with a mission. Sing stories of love. In fact our whole idea of love. These things are usually about how it feels during those first moments of falling in love.
所以今天，亲爱的听众，我们带着使命来到你们身边。歌颂爱的故事。事实上，我们关于爱的整个概念，通常都是关于坠入爱河最初几刻的感觉。
Today for Valentine's Day, as a public service, we make an attempt to understand another side of what love means. We bring you stories of couples that all take place decades after the moment their eyes meet.
今天情人节，作为一项公共服务，我们尝试去理解爱的另一种含义。我们带给你几对夫妻的故事，都发生在他们目光交汇几十年之后。
Act One, Before and After. The beginning of love as viewed from a moment near its ending. Act Two, I Met Him at the Yogurt Store, But I Do Not Call Him Leader of the Pack. Flirtation during marriage, a fable that could save your relationship, no kidding. Act Three, Without. Donald Hall documents a relationship whose most intense, most romantic moments came not at the beginning, but at the end. Stay with us.
第一幕，“之前与之后”。从临近终点的时刻去审视爱的开端。第二幕，“我在酸奶店遇见他，但我并不叫他‘头儿’”。婚姻中的调情，一个可以挽救你关系的故事，不开玩笑。第三幕，“缺失”。唐纳德·霍尔记录了一段关系，其最强烈、最浪漫的时刻并非出现在开头，而是出现在结尾。请留下来。
Act One, Before and After. As a kid growing up on the East Coast, in the 1970s, for me, the most romantic songs in the world-- and this is kind of a corny thing to admit now, years later with retrospect-- the most romantic songs in the world were Bruce Springsteen's. Songs about falling in love in run-down beach towns on the Jersey Shore, songs about hitting the road together to, you know, who knows where.
第一幕，“之前与之后”。作为一个在70年代东海岸长大的孩子，对我来说，世界上最浪漫的歌——现在回想起来承认这一点有点老土——世界上最浪漫的歌是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的歌。关于在泽西海岸破败的海滨小镇坠入爱河的歌，关于一起踏上旅程去往，你知道，谁知道哪里的歌。
But once Bruce hit a certain age, he stopped writing songs about that moment when lightning flashes between people, when their eyes meet.
但是当布鲁斯到了某个年纪，他不再写关于那种人与人之间闪电击中、目光交汇时刻的歌了。
And he wrote a series of songs where basically every song takes place long after the couple fell out of love. And the narrator, the singer of these songs, is remembering that exhilarating moment of falling in love, and then describing the moment he's in now, the drudgery of his marriage now. And he's laying these two moments side by side, trying to make sense of how one of them has any connection in the world to the other. How one of them led to the other.
他写了一系列歌曲，基本上每一首歌都发生在夫妻感情破裂很久之后。叙述者，这些歌的演唱者，回想着坠入爱河时的那种兴奋，然后描述他现在所处的时刻，现在婚姻中的琐碎苦役。他把这两个时刻并列在一起，试图理清这两者之间在这个世界上有什么联系。这两者是如何相互关联的。
Well, this next story is something like that. It's by Richard Bausch.
好吧，下一个故事就是这样的。作者是理查德·鲍什。
It's exactly 20 minutes to midnight on this, the eve of my 70th birthday. And I've decided to address you, for a change, in writing, odd as that might seem. I'm perfectly aware of how you're going to take the fact that I'm doing this at all, so late at night with everybody due to arrive tomorrow in the house, still unready.
现在是我70岁生日前夜的午夜前20分钟。我决定破天荒地用书信的方式对你说话，尽管这看起来很奇怪。我很清楚你会如何看待我竟然会在深夜做这种事，而明天家里人都快到了，还没准备好。
I haven't spent almost five decades with you without learning a few things about you that I can predict and describe with some accuracy. Though I admit that, as you put it, lately we've been more like strangers than husband and wife. Well, so if we are like strangers, perhaps there are some things I can tell you that you won't have already figured out about the way I feel.
我和你一起生活了近五十年，不可能不了解你的一些我可以准确预测和描述的事情。虽然我承认，正如你所说，最近我们与其说是夫妻，倒不如说是陌生人。好吧，如果我们要像陌生人一样，也许有些关于我的感受，我可以告诉你，是你还没察觉到的。
Tonight, we had another one of those long, silent evenings after an argument. Remember? Over pepper.
今晚，我们又经历了一个漫长、沉默的夜晚，在争吵之后。还记得吗？关于胡椒。
We had been bickering all day, really, but at dinner, I put pepper on my potatoes, and you said that about how I shouldn't have pepper because it always upsets my stomach. I bothered to remark that I used to eat chili peppers for breakfast, and if I wanted to put plain old ordinary black pepper on my potatoes, as I had been doing for more than 60 years, that was my privilege.
其实我们整天都在拌嘴，但在吃晚饭时，我在土豆上撒了胡椒，你说了那样的话，说我不该吃胡椒，因为它总是弄坏我的胃。我费心反驳说我以前早餐都吃辣椒，如果我想在土豆上撒点普普通通的黑胡椒，就像我过去60多年来一直做的那样，那是我的特权。
Writing this now, it sounds far more testy than I meant it. But that isn't really the point. In any case, you chose to overlook my tone. You simply said, John, you were up all night the last time you had pepper with your dinner. I said, I was up all night because I ate green peppers. Not black pepper, but green pepper. A pepper is a pepper, isn't it? You said.
现在写下来，听起来比我预想的要易怒得多。但这并不是重点。无论如何，你选择了无视我的语气。你只是说：“约翰，你上次晚饭吃胡椒后整晚都没睡好。”我说：“我整晚没睡是因为我吃了青椒。不是黑胡椒，是青椒。”你说：“胡椒就是胡椒，不是吗？”
And then I started in on you. I got, as you call it, legal with you, pointing out that green peppers are not black pepper. And from there we moved on to an evening of mutual disregard for each other that ended with your decision to go to bed early.
然后我就开始针对你了。我变得——正如你所说的——和你讲起理来，指出青椒不是黑胡椒。从那以后，我们就陷入了一个互相冷漠的夜晚，最终以你决定早点上床睡觉而告终。
The grandchildren will make you tired, and there's still the house to do. You had every reason to want to get some rest. And yet I felt that you were also making a point of getting yourself out of proximity with me, leaving me to my displeasure, with another ridiculous argument settling between us like a fog.
孙辈们会让你疲惫，屋子里还有事要做。你完全有理由想休息。然而我觉得你也是故意想要离我远一点，让我独自面对自己的不满，让又一场荒谬的争吵像雾一样笼罩在我们之间。
So after you went to bed, I got out the whiskey and started pouring drinks, and I had every intention of putting myself into a stupor. It was also my birthday after all and, forgive this, it's the way I felt at the time, you had nagged me into an argument and then gone off to bed. The day had ended as so many of our days end now and I felt, well, entitled. I had a few drinks, without any appreciable effect, though you might well see this letter as firm evidence to the contrary.
所以你上床睡觉后，我拿出了威士忌开始倒酒，我有意让自己陷入麻木。毕竟这是我的生日，而且——请原谅——这是我当时的感受，你唠叨着让我吵架，然后就上床睡觉了。这一天就这样结束了，就像我们现在的许多日子一样，我觉得，好吧，理应如此。我喝了几杯，虽然没什么明显的效果，尽管你很可能会把这封信看作是事实相反的有力证据。
And then I decided to do something to shake you up. I would leave. I'd make a lot of noise going out the door. I'd take a walk around the neighborhood and make you wonder where I could be. Perhaps I'd go check into a motel for the night. The thought even crossed my mind that I might leave you all together. I admit that I entertained the thought, Marie.
然后我决定做点什么让你吃惊。我要离开。出门时我会弄出很大的动静。我会在附近散散步，让你想知道我在哪里。也许我会去汽车旅馆开个房住一晚。我甚至想过干脆离开你。我承认我确实有过这个念头，玛丽。
I saw our life together now as the day to day round of petty quarreling and tension, that it's mostly been over the past couple of years or so. And I wanted out as sincerely as I ever wanted out of anything.
我看到我们现在的生活，就是过去几年里那种琐碎的争吵和紧张的日常循环。我真诚地想要逃离，就像我曾经真诚地想要逃离任何事情一样。
And I got up from my seat in front of the television, and walked back down the hall to the entrance of our room to look at you. I suppose I hoped you'd still be awake so I could tell you of this momentous decision I felt I'd reached. And maybe you were awake, one of our oldest areas of contention being the noise I make. The feather thin membrane of your sleep that I'm always disturbing with my restlessness in the nights. All right?
我从电视机前的座位上站起来，走回走廊到我们的房间入口处看你。我猜我希望你还没睡，这样我就能告诉你我感到的这个重大决定。也许你确实醒着，我们最古老的争论点之一就是我制造的噪音。你睡眠的羽毛般脆弱的薄膜，我总是因为夜里的烦躁不安而打扰它。好吧？
Assuming you were asleep and don't know that I stood in the doorway of our room, I will say that I stood there for perhaps five minutes looking at you in the half-dark, the shape of your body under the blanket. You really did look like one of the girls when they were little and I used to stand in the doorway of their rooms. Your illness last year made you so small again and, as I said, I thought I had decided to leave you, for your peace as well as mine.
假设你睡着了，不知道我站在我们的房间门口，我会说我站在那儿看了你大约五分钟，在半暗的光线里，毯子下你的身体轮廓。你看上去真的就像女儿们小时候一样，那时我也常站在她们的房门口。去年你的病让你再次变得那么瘦小，而且正如我所说，我想我决定离开你，为了你的安宁，也为了我的。
I know you have gone to sleep crying, Marie. I know you've felt sorry about things and wished we could find some way to stop irritating each other so much.
我知道你是哭着入睡的，玛丽。我知道你对事情感到遗憾，希望我们能找到某种方法停止这样互相折磨。
Well of course, I didn't go anywhere. I came back to this room and drank more of the whiskey and watched television. It was like all the other nights. The shows came on and ended, and the whiskey began to wear off. There was a little rain shower. I had a moment of the shock of knowing I was 70.
好吧，当然，我哪儿也没去。我回到了这个房间，喝了更多的威士忌，看着电视。就像其他所有的夜晚一样。节目开始又结束，威士忌的酒劲也开始消退。下了一场小雨。我有了一瞬间意识到自己70岁的震惊。
After the rain ended, I did go outside for a few minutes. I stood on the sidewalk and looked at the house. The kids, with their kids, were on the road somewhere between their homes and here. I walked up to the end of the block and back, and a pleasant breeze blew and shook the drops out of the trees. My stomach was bothering me some and maybe it was the pepper I put on my potatoes. It could just as well have been the whiskey.
雨停后，我确实出门走了几分钟。我站在人行道上看着房子。孩子们带着他们的孩子，在从他们家到这里的路上的某个地方。我走到街区尽头又走回来，一阵惬意的微风吹过，震落了树上的水滴。我的胃有点不舒服，也许是我在土豆上撒的胡椒。也完全可能是因为威士忌。
Anyway, as I came back to the house I began to have the eerie feeling that I had reached the last night of my life. There was this small discomfort in my stomach and no other physical pang or pain, and I am used to the small ills and side effects of my ways of eating and drinking. Yet I felt a sense of the end of things more strongly than I can describe.
无论如何，当我回到屋子时，我开始有一种诡异的感觉，觉得这是我生命的最后一个夜晚。我的胃部有轻微的不适，没有其他生理上的疼痛，我习惯了我的饮食方式带来的小毛病。然而，我感受到了一种强烈的终结感，强烈到无法形容。
When I stood in the entrance of our room and looked at you again, wondering if I would make it through to the morning, I suddenly found myself trying to think what I would say to you if indeed this were the last time I would ever be able to speak to you. And I began to know I would write you this letter.
当我再次站在我们房间门口看着你，想知道我是否能撑到天亮时，我突然发现自己试图想，如果这确实是我最后一次能和你说话，我会对你说什么。于是我开始知道，我会写这封信给你。
At least words in a letter aren't blurred by tone of voice, by the old aggravating sound of me talking to you.
至少信里的文字不会被语气，不会被我那令人恼火的说话声所模糊。
I began with this and with the idea that, after months of thinking about it, I would at last try to say something to you that wasn't colored by our disaffection. What I have to tell you must be explained in a rather roundabout way.
我从这里开始，从这个想法出发：在思考了几个月后，我终于试着对你说一些不被我们的疏离所渲染的话。我必须以一种相当迂回的方式来解释我要告诉你的事情。
I've been thinking about my cousin Louise and her husband. When he died and she stayed with us last summer, something brought back to me what is really only the memory of a moment. Yet it reached me, that moment, across more than 50 years.
我一直在想我的表妹路易丝和她的丈夫。当他去世，她去年夏天和我们住在一起时，有什么东西勾起了我这段记忆，真的只是一个瞬间的记忆。然而，它穿过了50多年，触动了我。
As you know, Louise is nine years older than I and more like an older sister than a cousin. I must have told you at one time or another that I spent some weeks with her back in 1933 when she was first married. The memory I'm talking about comes from that time, and what I have decided I have to tell you comes from that memory.
你知道，路易丝比我大九岁，比起表妹，更像是一个姐姐。我一定在某个时候告诉过你，1933年她刚结婚时，我和她住过几个星期。我说的这段记忆就来自那个时期，而我决定告诉你的一切，都来自那段记忆。
Father had been dead four years. We were all used to the fact that times were hard and that there was no man in the house, though I suppose I filled that role in some titular way.
父亲去世已经四年了。我们都习惯了日子过得艰难，家里没有男人的事实，虽然我想我在名义上填补了那个角色。
In any case, when Mother became ill, there was the problem of us, her children. Though I was the oldest, I wasn't old enough to stay in the house alone or to nurse her either. My grandfather came up with a solution and everybody went along with it, that I would go to Louise's for a time and the two girls would go to stay with grandfather.
无论如何，当母亲病倒时，我们的安置成了问题。虽然我是最大的，但我还不够大，不能独自留在屋里，也不能照顾她。祖父想出了一个解决方案，大家都同意了，我暂时去路易丝家，两个女孩去祖父家住。
So we closed up the house, and I got on a train to Virginia. I was a few weeks shy of 14 years old. I remember that I was not able to believe that anything truly bad would come of Mother's pleurisy and was consequently glad of the opportunity it afforded me to travel the 100 miles south to Charlottesville, where cousin Louise had moved with her new husband only a month earlier after her wedding.
所以我们锁好了房子，我坐火车去了弗吉尼亚。那时我离14岁还差几周。我记得我无法相信母亲的胸膜炎会带来真正严重的后果，因此很高兴有机会去往100英里外的夏洛茨维尔，那是路易丝表姐在结婚一个月后和新婚丈夫搬去的地方。
Because we traveled so much at the beginning, you never got to really know Charles when he was young. In 1933 he was a very tall, imposing fellow with bright red hair and a graceful way of moving that always made me think of athletics and contests of skill. He had worked at the Navy Yard in Washington and had been laid off in the first months of Roosevelt's New Deal. Louise was teaching in a day school in Charlottesville so they could make ends meet, and Charles was spending most of his time looking for work and fixing up the house.
因为我们刚开始时旅行太多，你从来没真正了解年轻时的查尔斯。1933年，他是一个非常高大、魁梧的人，有着鲜红的头发，走起路来优雅的样子总让我想到体育比赛。他在华盛顿的海军工厂工作，但在罗斯福“新政”的头几个月被裁员了。路易丝在夏洛茨维尔的一所走读学校教书，好维持生计，查尔斯大部分时间都在找工作和修缮房子。
I had only met Charles once or twice before the wedding, but already I admired him and wanted to emulate him. The prospect of spending time in his house, of perhaps going fishing with him in the small streams of central Virginia, was all I thought about on the way down. And I remember that we did go fishing one weekend, that I wound up spending a lot of time with Charles, helping to paint the house and to run water lines under it for indoor plumbing.
结婚前我只见过查尔斯一两次，但我已经很钦佩他，想要效仿他。在去那里的路上，我脑子里想的都是在他的房子里待上一段时间，也许和他去弗吉尼亚中部的小溪里钓鱼。我记得那个周末我们确实去钓鱼了，我也最终花了很多时间和查尔斯在一起，帮着粉刷房子，在底下铺设室内水管。
Oh, I had time with Louise too, listening to her read from the books she wanted me to be interested in, walking with her around Charlottesville in the evenings and looking at the city as it was then. Or sitting on her small porch and talking about the family, Mother's stubborn illness, the children Louise saw every day at school.
噢，我也和路易丝在一起待过，听她读她想让我感兴趣的书，傍晚和她一起在夏洛茨维尔周围散步，看着那时的城市。或者坐在她的小门廊上谈论家庭、母亲顽固的疾病，以及路易丝每天在学校见到的孩子们。
But what I want to tell you has to do with the very first day I was there. I know you think I use far too much energy thinking about and pining away for the past. And I therefore know that I am taking a risk by talking about this ancient history and by trying to make you see it. But this all has to do with you and me, my dear, and our late inability to find ourselves in the same room together without bitterness and pain.
但我想要告诉你的是关于我到那里的第一天的事情。我知道你认为我花了太多的精力去怀念过去。因此我也知道，谈论这段古老的历史并试图让你看到它是在冒风险。但这与你我有关，亲爱的，与我们最近无法在同一个房间里而不产生苦涩和痛苦有关。
That summer, 1933, was unusually warm in Virginia and the heat, along with my impatience to arrive, made the train almost unbearable. I think it was just past noon when it pulled into the station at Charlottesville, with me hanging out one of the windows looking for Louise or Charles. It was Charles who had come to meet me. He stood in a crisp looking seersucker suit, with a straw boater cocked at just the angle you'd expect a young, newly married man to wear a straw boater, even in the middle of economic disaster.
1933年那个夏天，弗吉尼亚异常炎热，加上我急于到达的心情，让火车变得难以忍受。我想刚过中午它就驶进了夏洛茨维尔车站，我探出窗外寻找路易丝或查尔斯。是查尔斯来接我。他穿着一件干练的泡泡纱西装，戴着一顶草帽，角度刚好是一个年轻、新婚的男人即使在经济大萧条时期也会戴出的角度。
I waved at him and he waved back. And I might have jumped out the window if the train had slowed even a little more than it had, before it stopped in the shade of the platform. I made my way out, carrying a cloth bag my grandfather had given me for the trip. Mother had said through her room that I looked like a carpetbagger. And when I stepped down to shake hands with Charles, I noticed that what I thought was a new suit was tattered at the ends of the sleeves.
我向他挥手，他也挥手回礼。如果火车再减速一点，在平台树荫下停稳前，我可能就直接跳出窗外了。我拿着祖父给我的布包走了出来。母亲在房间里说过，我看起来像个投机商。当我下车和查尔斯握手时，我注意到我以为是新的西装在袖口已经破烂了。
Well, he said, young John. I smiled at him. I was perceptive enough to see that his cheerfulness was not entirely effortless. He was a man out of work, after all, and so in spite of himself there was worry in his face, the slightest shadow in an otherwise glad and proud countenance.
“好吧，”他说，“小约翰。”我对他笑了笑。我有足够的敏锐度看出他的开朗并非完全不费力。毕竟他是个失业的人，所以尽管他表现得开朗，他的脸上仍有一丝忧虑，在那张本该愉悦而骄傲的脸上投下了阴影。
We walk through the station to the street and on up the steep hill to the house, which was a small clapboard structure, a cottage really, with a porch, at the end of a short sidewalk lined with flowers. They were marigolds, I think. And here was Louise, coming out of the house, her arms already stretched wide to embrace me.
我们穿过车站走到街上，爬上陡峭的山坡来到房子，那是一座小的木板结构建筑，其实就是个小屋，有个门廊，在一条花朵簇拥的人行道尽头。我想那是万寿菊。路易丝从屋里出来，双臂张开拥抱我。
Lord, she said, I swear you've grown since the wedding, John. Charles took my bag and went inside. Let me look at you, young man, Louise said. I stood for inspection. And as she looked me over, I saw that her hair was pulled back, that a few strands of it had come loose, that it was brilliantly auburn in the sun.
“天哪，”她说，“我发誓你自结婚起又长高了，约翰。”查尔斯拿过我的包进了屋子。“让我看看你，年轻人，”路易丝说。我站着接受检查。当她打量我时，我看到她的头发往后扎着，几缕发丝散落下来，在阳光下呈现出灿烂的赤褐色。
I suppose I was little in love with her. She was grown and married now. She was a part of what seemed a great mystery to me even as I was about to enter it. And of course, you remember how that feels, Marie, when one is on the verge of things, nearly adult, nearly old enough to fall in love.
我想我有点暗恋她。她现在是个成年人了，还结了婚。即便在我即将踏入它时，她对我来说依然是一个巨大的谜。当然，你记得那是什么感觉，玛丽，当一个人处于成年的边缘，快要大到可以坠入爱河的时候。
I looked at Louise's happy, flushed face and felt a deep ache as she ushered me into her house. I wanted so to be older.
我看着路易丝快乐、泛红的脸庞，当她领我进屋时，我感到一阵深深的痛楚。我多想自己能长大。
Inside, Charles had poured lemonade for us and was sitting in the easy chair by the fireplace already sipping his. Louise wanted to show me the house and the backyard, which she had tilled and turned into a small vegetable garden. But she must have sensed how thirsty I was. And so she asked me to sit down and have a cool drink before she showed me the upstairs.
屋里，查尔斯为我们倒了柠檬水，已经坐在壁炉旁的扶手椅上啜饮了。路易丝想带我参观房子和后院，她把它翻耕成了一个小菜园。但她一定察觉到了我有多渴。所以她叫我坐下喝点凉饮，然后再带我去看楼上。
Now, of course, looking back on it, I remember that those rooms she was so anxious to show me were meager indeed. They were not much bigger than closets really, and the paint was faded and dull. The furniture she'd arranged so artfully was coming apart. The pictures she put on the walls were prints she'd cut out, magazine covers mostly. And the curtains over the windows were the same ones that hung in her childhood bedroom for 20 years.
当然，现在回想起来，我记得那些她急于向我展示的房间实际上真的很寒酸。它们比壁橱大不了多少，油漆褪色又暗淡。她精心布置的家具正在散架。墙上的画是她剪下来的印花，大部分是杂志封面。窗上的窗帘是她童年卧室里挂了20年的那种。
Recognize these? She said with a deprecating smile. Of course the quality of her pride had nothing to do with the fineness, or lack of it, in these things, but in the fact that they belonged to her, and that she was a married lady in her own house.
“认出这些了吗？”她带着自嘲的微笑说。当然，她骄傲的品质与这些东西的精致与否无关，而在于这些东西属于她，而且她是在自己家里的已婚少妇。
On this day in July in 1933, she and Charles are waiting for the delivery of a fan they had scrounged enough money to buy from Sears through the catalog. There were things they would rather have been doing, especially in this heat, and especially with me there. Monticello wasn't far away. The university was within walking distance. And without too much expense, one could ride a taxi to one of the lakes nearby.
在1933年7月的这一天，她和查尔斯正在等待风扇的送货，那是他们从西尔斯目录上省吃俭用买来的。在这个炎热的天气里，加上我在这里，他们本可以做很多事。蒙蒂塞洛就在附近。大学也在步行范围之内。而且不用花太多钱，就可以坐出租车去附近的湖泊之一。
They had hoped that the fan would arrive before I did. But since it hadn't, and since neither Louise nor Charles was willing to leave the other alone while traipsing off with me that day, there wasn't anything to do but wait around for it. Louise had opened the windows and shut the shades, and we sat in her small living room and drank the lemonade, fanning ourselves with folded parts of Charles's morning newspaper. From time to time an anemic breath of air would move the shades slightly, but everything grew still again.
他们希望风扇在我到之前就送达。但既然没送达，而路易丝和查尔斯又都不愿意留对方一人，好带我那天到处乱逛，所以除了等货别无他法。路易丝打开了窗户关上窗帘，我们坐在小客厅里喝着柠檬水，用查尔斯晨报的折叠页给自己扇风。不时有一阵贫血般的微风轻轻吹动窗帘，但一切又恢复了平静。
Louise sat on the arm of Charles's chair and I sat on the sofa. We talked about pleurisy and, I think, about the fact that Thomas Jefferson had invented the dumbwaiter, how the plumbing at Monticello was at least a century ahead of its time. Charles remarked that it was the spirit of invention that would make a man's career in these days. That's what I'm aiming for, to be inventive in a job, no matter what it winds up being.
路易丝坐在查尔斯椅子的扶手上，我坐在沙发上。我们谈论胸膜炎，还有，我想，谈论托马斯·杰斐逊发明了传菜梯，以及蒙蒂塞洛的水管设备比时代超前了至少一个世纪。查尔斯感叹道，正是这种发明精神会在当下造就一个人。“这就是我的目标，在工作中进行发明，不管最终结果如何。”
When the lemonade ran out, Louise got up and went into the kitchen to make some more. Charles and I talked about taking a weekend to go fishing. He leaned back in his chair and put his hands behind his head, looking satisfied. In the kitchen Louise was chipping ice for our glasses and she began singing something low, for her own pleasure. A barely audible lilting. And Charles and I sat listening.
柠檬水喝完后，路易丝起身去厨房再做一些。查尔斯和我谈起找个周末去钓鱼。他向后靠在椅子上，双手枕在脑后，看起来很满足。在厨房里，路易丝正在为我们的杯子敲冰块，她开始低声哼唱，自得其乐。一阵几乎听不见的轻快的吟唱。查尔斯和我坐在那儿听着。
It occurred to me that I was very happy. I had the sense that soon I would be embarked on my own life as Charles was, and that an attractive woman like Louise would be there with me.
我突然觉得我非常快乐。我感到不久我也将像查尔斯一样开始我自己的生活，而像路易丝这样有魅力的女人也会出现在我身边。
Charles yawned and said, god listen to that. Doesn't Louise have the loveliest voice?
查尔斯打了个哈欠说：“上帝，听听这个。路易丝的声音难道不美妙吗？”
And that's all I have from that day. I don't even know if the fan arrived later, and I have no clear memory of how we spent the rest of the afternoon and evening. I remember Louise singing a song, her husband leaning back in his chair, folding his hands behind his head, expressing his pleasure in his young wife's voice. I remember that I felt quite extraordinarily content just then. And that's all I remember.
那天我记得的就这些了。我甚至不知道风扇后来是否送达，也不记得我们那天下午和晚上是怎么过的。我记得路易丝唱着歌，她丈夫向后靠在椅子上，把手枕在脑后，表达着对年轻妻子声音的喜爱。我记得那时我感到一种特别的满足。我记得的就只有这些。
But there are, of course, the things we both know. We know they moved to Colorado to be near Charles's parents. We know they never had any children. We know that Charles fell down a shaft at a construction site in the fall of 1957 and was hurt so badly that he never walked again. And I know that when she came to stay with us last summer, she told me she learned to hate him. And not for what she'd had to help him do all those years. No, it started earlier and was deeper than that. She hadn't minded the care of him, the washing and feeding, and all the numberless small tasks she had to perform each and every day, all day. She hadn't minded this. In fact, she thought there was something in her makeup that liked being needed so completely.
当然，我们都知道一些后续的事情。我们知道他们搬到了科罗拉多，为了靠近查尔斯的父母。我们知道他们没有孩子。我们知道查尔斯在1957年秋天在建筑工地坠入井道，伤势极其严重，从此再也没能站起来。我也知道，当她去年夏天来和我们住在一起时，她告诉我她学会了恨他。不是因为那些年来她不得不照顾他。不，这开始得更早，也更深刻。她并不介意照顾他，洗澡和喂食，以及她每天从早到晚必须执行的无数小事。她并不介意这些。事实上，她认为自己本质里有什么东西是喜欢被完全需要的。
The trouble was simply that whatever she had once loved in him, she had stopped loving. And for many, many years before he died, she'd felt only suffocation when he was near enough to touch her. Only irritation and anxiety when he spoke.
问题仅仅在于，无论她曾经爱他什么，她都已经不再爱了。在他去世前的许多许多年里，当他靠近到能触碰她时，她感到的只有窒息。当他说话时，她感到的只有烦躁和焦虑。
She said all this and then looked at me, her cousin, who had been fortunate enough to have children and to be in love over time, and said, John, how have you and Marie managed it? And what I wanted to tell you has to do with this fact. That while you and I had had one of our whispering arguments only moments before, I feel quite certain of the simple truth of the matter, which is that whatever our complications, we have managed to be in love over time.
她说了这一切，然后看着我，她的表弟，一个幸运地有了孩子并能随着时间推移保持恋爱的人，然后说：“约翰，你和玛丽是怎么做到的？”我想要告诉你的一切都与这个事实有关。即便是我们刚才还进行了争吵，我也感到某种简单的真理，那就是，不管我们有多少麻烦，我们确实成功地随着时间推移保持了爱。
Louise, I said.
“路易丝，”我说。
People start out with such high hopes, she said, as if I wasn't there. She looked at me. Don't they?
“人们开始时都怀着如此美好的希望，”她说，好像我不在那里一样。她看着我，“不是吗？”
Yes, I said.
“是的，”我说。
She seemed to consider this a moment and she said, I wonder how it happens.
她似乎考虑了一会儿，然后说：“我想知道那是怎么发生的。”
I said, you ought to get some rest, or something equally pointless and admonitory.
我说：“你该休息一下了，”或者说了些同样毫无意义和告诫的话。
As she moved away from me, I had an image of Charles standing on the station platform in Charlottesville that summer, the straw boater set at its cocky angle. It was an image I would see most of the rest of that night, and on many another night since.
当她从我身边走开时，我脑海中浮现出查尔斯那天夏天站在夏洛茨维尔车站平台上的样子，草帽戴在那个傲慢的角度。那是我在接下来的大部分时间里，以及此后的许多个夜晚里都会看到的形象。
I can almost hear your voice as you point out that once again I've managed to dwell too long on the memory of something that's passed and gone. The difference is that I'm not grieving over the past now. I am merely reporting a memory, so that you might understand what I'm about to say to you.
我几乎能听到你的声音，指出我再次执着于沉湎于过去已逝的事物。区别在于我现在并不是在哀悼过去。我只是在报告一段记忆，好让你理解我正要对你说的话。
The fact is, we aren't the people we were even then, just a year ago. I know that. As I know things have been slowly eroding between us for a very long time. We are a little tired of each other. And there are annoyances and old scars that won't be obliterated with a letter, even a long one written in the middle of the night in desperate sincerity, under the influence, admittedly, of a considerable portion of bourbon whiskey. But nevertheless with the best intention and hope that you may know how, over the course of this night, I came to the end of needing an explanation for our difficulty.
事实是，我们已经不再是当时的我们了，甚至不是一年前的我们。我知道。就像我知道我们之间的裂痕已经很久很久了。我们对彼此感到有点厌倦。还有一些恼人的旧伤疤，不是一封信就能抹平的，即使这是一封在深夜里绝望地真诚写就、承认是在相当一部分波本威士忌的影响下写成的长信。但尽管如此，我带着最好的意愿和希望，希望你能知道，在这一晚的过程中，我是如何不再需要为我们的困境寻求解释的。
We have reached this place. Everything we say seems rather aggravatingly mindless and automatic, like something one stranger might say to another in one of the thousand circumstances where strangers are thrown together for a time, and the silence begins to grow heavy on their minds and someone has to say something.
我们到了这一步。我们所说的一切似乎都相当令人恼火地空洞和自动，就像两个陌生人在某种情况下被抛在一起，当沉默开始在他们的脑海中变得沉重，有人必须说点什么时，陌生人之间可能会说的那些话。
Darling, we go so long these days without having anything at all to do with each other. And the children are arriving tomorrow, and once more we'll be in the position of making all the gestures that give them back their parents as they think their parents are. And what I wanted to say to you, what came to me as I thought about Louise and Charles on that day so long ago, when they were young and so obviously glad of each other. And I looked at them and knew it and was happy. What came to me was that even the harsh things that happened to them, even the years of anger and silence, even the disappointment and the bitterness and the wanting not to be in the same room anymore. Even all that must have been worth it, for such loveliness.
亲爱的，这些日子我们相处的时间太久，却什么事都没在一起做。孩子们明天要到了，我们又一次要摆出姿态，把他们认为的父母还给他们。而我想对你说的是，当我想到那么久以前路易丝和查尔斯那天，当他们年轻且明显为对方感到高兴时，那些念头出现在我脑海里。我看着他们，知道那一点，并感到快乐。出现在我脑海里的是，即使那些发生在他们身上的残酷事情，即使多年来的愤怒和沉默，即使失望和痛苦，以及不想再待在同一个房间里的愿望。即使所有这一切，为了那种美好，也一定是值得的。
At least I am here at 70 years old hoping so.
至少我在这里，70岁了，还心存希望。
Tonight, I went back to our room again and stood gazing at you asleep, dreaming whatever you were dreaming. And I had a moment of thinking how we were always friends too.
今晚，我再次回到我们的房间，注视着熟睡的你，梦着无论你在梦着什么。我那一瞬间想到，我们也是永远的朋友。
Because what I wanted finally to say, was that I remember well our own sweet times, our own old loveliness. And I would like to think that even if at the very beginning of our lives together, I had somehow been shown that we would end up here, with this longing to be away from each other, this feeling of being trapped together, of being tied to each other in a way that makes us wish for other times, some other place, I would have known enough to accept it all freely for the chance at that love.
因为我最终想说的是，我清楚地记得我们自己的甜蜜时光，我们古老的美好。我愿意相信，即使在我们共同生活的最初，我以某种方式被告知我们最终会走到这一步，这种想要远离对方的渴望，这种被困在一起的感觉，这种以某种方式让我们渴望其他时间、其他地点的牵绊，我也会有足够的认知，为了那种爱的机会去欣然接受这一切。
And if I could, I would do it all again, Marie. All of it. Even the sorrow. My sweet, my dear adversary, for everything that I remember.
如果可以，玛丽，我愿意重来一次。这一切。即使是那些悲伤。我甜蜜的、亲爱的对手，为了我所记得的一切。
Richard Bausch's story, "Letter to the Lady of the House," is in his book, Selected Stories from Richard Bausch. That's from the Modern Library. His newest book is called In The Night Season.
理查德·鲍什的故事《给女主人的信》收录在他的书《理查德·鲍什精选集》中。那是来自现代文库。他最新的书叫做《在夜之季》。
Coming up, not leaving your husband for the guy in the yogurt store, despite his nose job. That's in a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continuous.
接下来，不要因为那个做过鼻整形手术的酸奶店男人而离开你的丈夫。那是来自国际公共广播电台的节目，稍后回到我们的节目。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and performers to tackle that theme.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨这个主题。
Today, for Valentine's Day, we wanted to bring you stories about love, but not the usual kind of love stories which try to capture that moment when your eyes meet and your heart sings, and you fall, fall, fall, fall, fall. No, no, no. We have a different mission. Today, as a public service, we are bringing you love stories about people who have been in the same relationship for years. Stories of love years after the lightning has already struck.
今天，为了情人节，我们想带给你关于爱的故事，但不是那种试图捕捉你目光交汇、心跳加速、坠入爱河瞬间的普通爱情故事。不，不，不。我们有不同的使命。今天，作为一项公共服务，我们为你带来关于在同一段关系中维持多年的人们的爱情故事。那些闪电击中多年后的爱情故事。
We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, I met him in the yogurt store, and now he is not my leader of the pack.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“我在酸奶店遇见他，现在他不再是我的领头羊”。
In this act we bring you a true fable of love, a true story. A tale of moral instruction with a lesson for everyone, that happened in the ninth year of marriage between Linda Howard and Richard Bloom, who live in Boca Raton, Florida.
在这一幕中，我们为你带来一个真实的爱的寓言，一个真实的故事。一个关于道德指导和给每个人上一课的故事，发生在琳达·霍华德和理查德·布鲁姆这对住在佛罗里达州博卡拉顿的夫妇婚姻的第九年。
After we were married I would say-- was Nicole born yet? Yeah, we had both kids, we had a boy and a girl. And we were-- took the kids out for frozen yogurt one night. And we're in Huntington, where we lived at the time. And we're sitting down, we're ordering, and there's this guy, very good-looking guy standing there, and all of a sudden--
“结婚后我会说——妮可出生了吗？是的，我们有了两个孩子，一男一女。我们带孩子去吃冷冻酸奶，那时我们住在亨廷顿。我们坐下来，下单，然后有个家伙，非常帅的家伙站在那里，突然之间——”
He wasn't that good-looking.
“他没那么帅。”
All of a sudden, it dawned on me that this was David, this guy who I dated in high school and then years later, had another relationship with, which was kind of a hot and heavy relationship several years later, when we were already out of school for a number of years. And here he was. He had had his nose fixed, and his hair was all white, and to me he looked absolutely gorgeous. And I said, David? Now, his whole family's there. He says, Linda?
“突然之间，我意识到那是大卫，我在高中时约会过的家伙，几年后，我们又有过另一段关系，那是在我们毕业几年后，一段相当火热的关系。他竟然就在这里。他的鼻子做过整形，头发全白了，但在我看来他简直帅呆了。我说：‘大卫？’他的全家人都在那儿。他说：‘琳达？’”
And it was like everything stopped in my mind at that moment. And it was kind of like we were trying to be very nonchalant with each other here. Oh, this is my husband and these are my kids, and dah dah dah. Meanwhile, the heart is going, ba-boom, ba-boom, ba-boom, ba-boom.
“那一瞬间，我脑子里什么都停了。我们似乎都在试图显得非常漫不经心。‘哦，这是我丈夫，这是我的孩子，等等等等。’与此同时，心在怦怦直跳，怦怦，怦怦，怦怦。”
And I know it's an old boyfriend, I could just tell. And I go, hi, I'm the husband. Hi. And my kids, hi.
“我知道那是前男友，我一眼就看出来了。我说：‘嗨，我是丈夫。嗨。’我的孩子们说：‘嗨。’”
So he and I have this nice little chat while we're standing there, and I'm saying to myself in the car, I know that he is thinking exactly the same thing about me. I know it. There's not a doubt in my mind. And I can't believe that we've just left now and we're not going to each other again.
“所以我和他站在那里聊得很开心，我在车里对自己说，我知道他在想完全一样的事情。我知道。我心里一点疑问都没有。我简直不敢相信我们刚离开，以后就再也不会见面了。”
I ask him, what is he doing? And he tells me that he's a psychoanalyst in the city, and this is completely a shock to me. And I tell them that I'm a clinical psychologist.
“我问他在做什么。他告诉我他是市里的精神分析学家，这对我来说完全是震惊。我告诉他们我是临床心理学家。”
And they have so much in common.
“他们有那么多共同点。”
We have so much in common and blah blah blah. Well, anyway.
“我们有很多共同点，等等等等。总之。”
The next day I go into my office and there's this-- I press the button on my answering machine-- and there's this long message. And I'm thinking, who could have left me a message that long? And I play it back.
“第二天我去办公室，我按下答录机的按钮，有一条很长的留言。我想：‘谁会给我留这么长的言？’我播放它。”
Somebody needed help.
“有人需要帮助。”
And it's David and he said-- I can't do that-- when I got in the car, I couldn't stop thinking about you and all of this kind of stuff. And I was just astounded and I had this big smile on my face, and I'm thinking, well there's no way I'm going to call him back.
“是大卫，他说——我做不到——当我上车时，我无法停止想你，还有所有这类事情。我简直惊呆了，脸上带着大大的微笑，心想，我绝对不可能给他回电话。”
So I don't call him back and a few days later he calls. And he had been saying to me that it was so wonderful to see me and he'd love to get together, and he was kind of reminiscing and so forth. And I didn't call him back. And he called back and he left another message, saying that he was sorry that he had gotten so carried away, and I probably have my own life now and a whole thing, and it's probably difficult for me to call and he understands, and just wanted me to know how great it was to see me and--
“所以我不回电话，几天后他打来了。他一直跟我说见到我太棒了，他很想见个面，他在怀旧等等。我没回电话。他又打来，留了另一条留言，说抱歉他太冲动了，我可能现在有自己的生活了，这对他来说很难打电话，他理解，只是想让我知道见到我有多棒——”
Probably have your own life, with the husband, the two kids. I wonder what gave it away.
“可能有自己的生活，带着丈夫和两个孩子。我想是什么让他意识到这一点。”
So anyway, at that point, when he said that, I waited a few days and it was just-- I just really wanted to talk to him.
“总之，在那一刻，当他说那些话时，我等了几天，我真的很想和他说话。”
So I called him and he said, why don't we meet for-- we had this fabulous, fabulous conversation-- and why don't we meet for coffee. And I got that old feeling. That old feeling of having that rush, you know. And somebody's going to think I'm fabulous all over again. So I started thinking about him and thinking about him. And he said, can we go for coffee? So I said I would think about it. So I said to Richard that night, oh I heard from David. And he said, oh yeah, what did he say? And I said, well, we just had a nice talk, and do you mind if we go for coffee? And he said, do I mind? Well, I wouldn't like it. But if that's what you'd like to do, go ahead.
“所以我给他打了电话，他说：‘我们何不找个机会见面——我们有了一次非常棒的对话——我们何不约杯咖啡。’我又有了那种老感觉。那种再次拥有的冲动，你知道。有人会再次认为我很棒。所以我开始想他，想他。他说：‘我们可以去喝杯咖啡吗？’我说我会考虑一下。那天晚上我对理查德说：‘哦，我收到大卫的消息了。’他说：‘哦，真的吗？他说什么？’我说：‘哦，我们只是聊得不错，介意我们去喝杯咖啡吗？’他说：‘我介意吗？好吧，我不喜欢。但如果这是你想做的，那就去吧。’”
So I thought about it. And now, in the meantime, he's leaving me messages now. And he's saying, I didn't think of you when I got up this morning, I just wanted you to know that I'm not thinking of you when having a coffee break, and these very seductive messages.
“所以我想了想。与此同时，他现在在给我留言。他说：‘我今天早上起床时没想起你，我只是想让你知道我在喝咖啡休息时也没想起你，’这些非常诱惑的留言。”
And I'm just getting obsessed with him, and I'm thinking oh my god I want to see him. Well, it got to a point where I wanted to see him so badly that I was upset. I could not look Richard in the eye. And he came home one Saturday afternoon and I was just terribly upset. I said, Rich, I have to talk to you. He said, what's the matter? And I told him the whole story.
“我对他越来越着迷，心想：‘天哪，我想见他。’好吧，到了我太想见他以至于我感到心烦意乱的地步。我无法直视理查德。星期六下午他回家时，我难过极了。我说：‘里奇，我得跟你谈谈。’他说：‘怎么了？’我告诉了他整个故事。”
And he was amazing. He put his arms around me-- I told him I'm obsessed with him-- he put his arms around me and he just held me. And he said to me, oh honey, I'm so sorry I can't do that for you anymore. And that was all he said. I couldn't believe it. I waited for some kind of a lecture, why didn't you tell me? Something, some sign of jealousy. Nothing, nothing, nothing. Just held me.
“他太棒了。他搂住我——我告诉他我对他着迷——他搂住我，只是抱着我。他说：‘哦，亲爱的，我很难过，我不能再为你做那种事了。’那是他说的全部。我简直不敢相信。我等着听什么教训，‘为什么你不早告诉我？’什么的，或者嫉妒的迹象。什么都没有。只是抱着我。”
I was jealous, because-- but what's it going to do? I mean once you've got two kids and you've been with each other for quite a while, before and after marriage, you can't get the thunder and lightning back. It's now-- it's different.
“我是嫉妒的，因为——但这有什么用呢？我的意思是，一旦你有两个孩子，在一起有一段时间了，无论是在婚姻前后，你就找不回那种雷鸣电闪了。现在——情况不同了。”
Needless to say, I went downstairs to my office and I called David immediately, and I said, this is what just happened. I've been obsessed with you. I told my husband the whole story from beginning to end and this is what he did. He put his arms around me and held me, and I told him what he said. And I said, this is the most amazing man in the world. And David said, you're married to one helluva guy.
“不用说，我下楼到办公室，立刻拨通了大卫的电话，我说：‘刚刚发生了这样的事。我一直对你着迷。我把整个故事从头到尾告诉了我丈夫，他就是这样做的。他搂住我，抱着我，我告诉了他他说的话。我说，这是世界上最棒的男人。’大卫说：‘你嫁给了一个了不起的家伙。’”
And I am. I am one helluva guy.
“而我是。我是个了不起的家伙。”
I said, yes he is. Don't ever call me again. And that was it.
“我说：‘是的，他是。别再给我打电话了。’就这样。”
Linda Howard and Richard Bloom have been married for 11 years. They spoke with Stephanie Howard.
琳达·霍华德和理查德·布鲁姆已经结婚11年了。他们接受了斯蒂芬妮·霍华德的采访。
[SINGING] Here's our story, it's sad but true.
[演唱] 这是我们的故事，悲伤但真实。
[SINGING] About a boy that I once knew.
[演唱] 关于一个我曾经认识的男孩。
[SINGING] I don't know the rest of the song.
[演唱] 我不知道这首歌剩下的部分。
[SINGING] I almost took his love and ran around.
[演唱] 我差点接受他的爱然后逃跑。
Act Three, Without. Donald Hall says that when he first got together with his wife, Jane Kenyon, the earliest years were not so very intense. They didn't have that big lightning moment. It was the '70s, he says, by way of explanation. They saw each other while they also saw other people. And then they slowly decided that they had no interest in the other people. And then they got married. And then, three years into the marriage, they moved to a farm in New Hampshire that had been in Donald's family for generations.
第三幕，“缺失”。唐纳德·霍尔说，当他和妻子简·凯尼恩第一次在一起时，最初的几年并没有那么强烈。他们没有那种巨大的闪电时刻。他解释说是70年代。他们在一起时也看着其他人。然后他们慢慢决定对其他人没有兴趣。然后他们结婚了。结婚三年后，他们搬到了新罕布什尔州的一个农场，那是唐纳德家族几代人传下来的。
And it was only then, Donald Hall says, that they entered their most intimate time together. They got closer every year of their marriage, he says, and the closest time of all between them came at the end of their marriage, when after 22 years together, Jane Kenyon got leukemia and he took care of her.
唐纳德·霍尔说，直到那时，他们才进入了彼此最亲密的时光。他说，他们结婚的每一年都越来越亲近，而他们之间最亲近的时刻出现在婚姻的尽头，在他们在一起22年后，简·凯尼恩患上了白血病，他照顾着她。
During this time, he started to document what was happening between them in his writing. And his newest book of poems, called Without, is all work he began during her illness and after her death in 1995. The poems include sad moments and funny moments, and a million little details of everyday life during a life-threatening crisis. In one poem, Jane stares at the mirror at her bald head and her face, swollen from the drugs that she's taking, and she declares, I am Telly Savalas.
在此期间，他开始在写作中记录他们之间发生的一切。他最新的诗集《缺失》，全是他从她患病期间开始，直到1995年她去世后完成的作品。这些诗包含悲伤的时刻、有趣的时刻，以及生命危机中日常生活的琐碎细节。在其中一首诗里，简看着镜中光秃秃的头和因服用药物而浮肿的脸，宣布道：“我是特利·萨瓦拉斯。”
In another, Donald asked, why were they not contented four months ago? Because Jane did not have leukemia? A year hence, would he question why he was not contented now? Therefore, he was contented.
在另一首里，唐纳德问道，为什么他们四个月前还不满足？因为简没有患白血病？一年后，他会质疑为什么现在不满足吗？因此，他满足了。
He writes about the dog Gus reacting to their illness, about Jane trying to finish her own book of poems called Otherwise , and about small moments when they both realize once again, all over again, what's happening to them.
他写了关于狗格斯对他们疾病的反应，关于简试图完成她自己的诗集《否则》，以及关于他们两人再次意识到这一切发生在他们身上那一刻的零星瞬间。
Alone together a moment on the 22nd anniversary of their wedding, he clasped her as she stood at the sink, pressing into her backside, rubbing his cheek against the stubble of her skull. He gave her a ring of pink tourmaline with nine small diamonds around it. She put it on her finger, and immediately named it Please Don't Die.
在结婚22周年纪念日的短暂独处中，当她站在水槽边时，他拥抱她，紧贴着她的后背，用脸蹭着她头骨上的短茬。他给了她一枚镶有九颗小钻石的粉色电气石戒指。她戴在手指上，立刻命名为“请不要死”。
They kissed and Jane whispered, timor mortis conturbat me. That last bit, of course, is Latin and Jane was not a Latin scholar, but that's a refrain line of a wonderful medieval Scots' poem about dead poets, and it translates more or less, the fear of death shakes me.
他们亲吻着，简低语道，“timor mortis conturbat me”。最后那句当然是拉丁文，简不是拉丁文学者，但那是一首美妙的中世纪苏格兰诗中关于已故诗人的副歌，大致翻译为“对死亡的恐惧震撼着我”。
Usually when we think about romance, the moment that we think about is the beginning of the romance as the most intense time. And in fact one of the things that happens in these poems is it's just the two of you going through a time that's just as intense.
通常当我们想到浪漫时，我们想到最强烈的时刻是浪漫的开端。事实上，这些诗中发生的一件事，正是你们两个人经历了一段同样强烈的时期。
Oh, more intense. More intense. Really, we had a very good marriage. We were very fortunate. We loved the same things. And then we began to be sick. I had cancer a couple of times and then Jane had leukemia, beginning at the age of 46 and dying at 47. Jane was 19 years younger than me. But when you think you're going to lose what you love, when you know it's probably going to happen, then the sweetness of the intensity and the pain of the intensity is greater than ever, I do think
“噢，更强烈。更强烈。真的，我们有很好的婚姻。我们非常幸运。我们热爱同样的东西。然后我们开始生病。我得过几次癌症，然后简患上了白血病，从46岁开始，在47岁去世。简比我小19岁。但当你认为你会失去你所爱的人时，当你知道这很可能会发生时，那种强烈的甜蜜和痛苦比以往任何时候都要强烈，我确实这么认为。”
I think it was beautiful. I often say that obviously the worst thing in my life is Jane dying. But one of the best things in my life was taking care of her.
“我觉得这很美。我常说简的去世显然是我生命中最糟糕的事情。但我生命中最好的事情之一就是照顾她。”
There's a line in one of the poems actually, where you say, he felt shamed to understand that he would miss the months of sickness and taking care.
诗中有一句，你说，“他感到羞愧，因为他会怀念生病和照顾她的那几个月。”
And I had that thought literally. It's all right to tell lies in books, but this was not a lie. I had that thought and wrote down something like that line the day before we found out that she was going to die.
“我当时确实是这么想的。书里可以撒谎，但这不是谎言。我在我们发现她快要去世的前一天想到了这个，写下了类似那句的话。”
I was optimistic. And I thought, with guilt, I'll be sorry when I can't take care of her anymore.
“我当时很乐观。带着愧疚，我想，我以后会因为不能再照顾她而感到遗憾。”
So explain this poem, "Last Days," to me.
“所以向我解释一下这首诗《最后的日子》。”
Well "Last Days" is the poems that I wrote or began to write during the last days of her life.
“《最后的日子》是我在她生命的最后几天写下或开始写的诗。”
One day in April we had her blood checked, which we did once a week, and it was just fine. And a week later, the leukemia had come back and there was nothing to do. She was going to die.
“四月的一天，我们检查了她的血液，我们每周做一次，结果很好。一周后，白血病复发了，无计可施。她要死了。”
This is after also she went through very intensive chemotherapy and radiation treatment, a bone marrow transplant--
“这是在她经历了高强度的化疗、放射治疗、骨髓移植之后——”
Everything. Yeah, 15 months of a lot of suffering. So this was what we came home with the doctor saying, it might be a month. But it actually took just 11 days. And here are poems out of those 11 days.
“所有的一切。是的，15个月的巨大痛苦。所以医生说这就是带她回家的结果，可能还有一个多月。但实际上只用了11天。这里是这11天的诗。”
OK.
“好的。”
Home that afternoon, they threw her medicines into the trash. Jane vomited. He wailed, while she remained dry-eyed, silent, trying to let go. At night, he picked up the telephone to make calls that brought a child or a friend into the horror.
“那天下午回到家，他们把她的药扔进垃圾桶。简呕吐了。他嚎啕大哭，而她保持干眼，沉默，试图放手。晚上，他拿起电话打给孩子或朋友，让他们面对这恐怖的现实。”
The next morning, they worked choosing among her poems for Otherwise , picked hymns for her funeral, and supplied each other words as they wrote and revised her obituary.
“第二天早上，他们忙着为《否则》挑选她的诗，选了她葬礼上的赞美诗，在撰写和修改她的讣告时互相提供词句。”
The day after, with more work to do on her book, he saw how weak she felt and said, maybe not now. Maybe later. Jane shook her head. Now, she said. We have to finish it now.
“之后的那天，虽然她的书还有更多工作要做，但他看到她感觉多么虚弱，说：‘也许不是现在。也许以后吧。’简摇了摇头。‘现在，’她说。‘我们必须现在完成它。’”
Later, as she slid exhausted into sleep, she said, wasn't that fun? To work together. Wasn't that fun?
“后来，当她疲惫地滑入睡眠时，她说：‘那不是很开心吗？一起工作。那不是很开心吗？’”
He asked her, what clothes should we dress you in when we bury you?
“他问她：‘我们埋葬你时该给你穿什么衣服？’”
I hadn't thought, she said.
“‘我没想过，’她说。”
I wondered about the white salwar kameez, he said, her favorite Indian silk they bought in Pondicherry a year and a half before, which she wore for best or prettiest afterward.
“‘我想到那件白色萨尔瓦卡米兹，’他说，她最爱的那件印度丝绸，他们一年半前在本地治里买的，她以前在最好的场合穿，后来最漂亮的时候也穿。”
She smiled. Yes, excellent, she said. He didn't tell her that a year earlier, dreaming awake, he had seen her in the coffin in her white salwar kameez.
“她笑了。‘是的，好极了，’她说。他没告诉她，一年前，他在清醒的梦中，曾看到她穿着白色萨尔瓦卡米兹躺在棺材里。”
They talked about their adventures, driving through England when they first married, and excursions to China and India. Also they remembered ordinary days, pond summers, working on poems together, walking the dog, reading Chekhov aloud.
“他们谈论他们的冒险，刚结婚时开车横穿英国，去中国和印度的旅行。他们也记得平凡的日子，池塘边的夏天，一起琢磨诗句，遛狗，大声读契诃夫。”
When he praised thousands of afternoon assignations that carried them into bliss and repose on this painted bed, Jane burst into tears and cried, no more [BLEEP]ing. No more [BLEEP]ing.
“当他赞美数千个午后的幽会，带给他们那张漆过的床上的极乐与休憩时，简泪流满面，大叫：‘别再[哔]了。别再[哔]了。’”
Incontinent three nights before she died, Jane needed lifting onto the commode. He wiped her and helped her back into bed. At 5:00 he fed the dog and returned to find her across the room, sitting in a straight chair. When she couldn't stand, how could she walk? He figured she would fall and called for an ambulance to the hospital. But when he told Jane, her mouth twisted down and tears started.
“去世前三个晚上，简大小便失禁，需要被抬到马桶上。他擦拭她，扶她回床。5点钟他喂了狗，回来发现她横跨在房间里，坐在一张直背椅上。当她不能站立时，怎么走得动？他以为她会摔倒，叫了救护车去医院。但当他告诉简时，她的嘴往下撇，眼泪流了下来。”
Do we have to? He canceled. Jane said, Perkins, be with me when I die.
“‘我们非得去吗？’他取消了。简说：‘帕金斯，我死的时候陪着我。’”
Dying is simple, she said. What's worst is the separation. When she no longer spoke, they lay alone together, touching, and she fixed on him her beautiful enormous round, brown eyes, shining, unblinking, and passionate with love and dread.
“‘死亡很简单，’她说。‘最糟的是分离。’当她不再说话时，他们独自躺在一起，相互触碰，她用那双美丽的、巨大的、圆圆的褐色眼睛紧盯着他，闪亮、不眨眼，充满了爱与恐惧。”
One by one, they came, the oldest and dearest, to say goodbye to this friend of the heart. At first she said their names, wept and touched, then she smiled. Then turned one mouth corner up. On the last day, she stared silent goodbyes, with her hands curled and her eyes stuck open.
“一个接一个，最亲密和最珍贵的人来了，与这位心灵的朋友告别。起初她叫出他们的名字，哭泣和触摸，然后她微笑了。然后嘴角向上弯起。最后一天，她盯着沉默的告别，双手蜷缩，眼睛睁得大大的。”
Leaving his place beside her, where her eyes stared, he told her, I'll put these letters in the box. She had not spoken for three hours. And now Jane said her last words, OK.
“离开她身边的位置，当她的眼睛瞪着时，他告诉她：‘我会把这些信放进盒子里。’她已经三个小时没说话了。现在简说了她最后的话：‘好的。’”
At 8:00 that night, her eyes open as they stayed until she died, brain-stem breathing started. He bent to kiss her pale cool lips again and felt them one last time gather and purse and peck to kiss him back.
“那天晚上8点，她的眼睛一直睁着直到去世，脑干呼吸开始了。他俯身再次亲吻她苍白凉爽的嘴唇，最后一次感受到它们聚集、收缩并啄吻回来。”
In the last hours, she kept her forearms raised with pale fingers clenched at cheek level, like the goddess figurine over the bathroom sink. Sometimes her right fist flicked or spasmed toward her face.
“在最后的几个小时里，她保持前臂抬起，苍白的手指在脸颊高度紧握，就像浴室水槽上方的那尊女神像。有时她的右拳会颤动或痉挛着伸向脸部。”
For 12 hours until she died, he kept scratching Jane Kenyon's big bony nose. A sharp, almost sweet smell began to rise from her open mouth.
“在她去世前的12个小时里，他一直挠着简·凯尼恩的大骨头鼻子。一股尖锐的、几乎是甜味的气味从她张开的嘴里散发出来。”
That's a line from her, by the way. She wrote a wonderful poem called Gettysburg. And she says a sharp, almost sweet smell began to rise from his open mouth. And nobody has noticed that yet. I'm ripping her off as she dies. She wouldn't mind. She'd be amused.
“顺便说一句，那也是她的一行诗。她写过一首美妙的诗叫《葛底斯堡》。她说‘一股尖锐的、几乎是甜味的气味从他张开的嘴里散发出来’。还没有人注意到这一点。我趁她死时偷用她的诗。她不会介意的。她会觉得有趣。”
Do you feel like going through the process of revising and finishing this book, and publishing it, has kept you suspended in that period of mourning for her longer than perhaps you would've otherwise?
“你觉得经历修改、完成这本书并出版它的过程，是否让你比原本可能的时间更久地悬浮在对她的哀悼期中？”
No, I don't think so. I think that it has been very helpful to me in my mourning. I don't think I would have straight away. But I had something to do about it.
“不，我不这么认为。我认为这对我的哀悼非常有帮助。我不认为我会直接走出来。但我有事可做。”
I really understand that. I think that one of the most common things when somebody is mourning somebody else, is you're not exactly sure what to do with the feeling.
“我真的理解。我认为当某人哀悼另一个人时，最常见的事情之一就是你不确定如何处理这种感觉。”
Yeah, yeah.
“是的，是的。”
It's like, they're unreachable. And then you have all this feeling, and it's like, well, where do you even put it?
“就像，他们遥不可及。然后你有这么多感受，就像，好吧，你把它放在哪里呢？”
Where do you put it, yeah. I had a place to put it. I had a reason to wake up in the morning. And especially the first year, when it was very acute, and I screamed a lot and scared the dog. But I had a reason to get up in the morning.
“放在哪里，是的。我有地方可以放。我有理由早上醒来。尤其是第一年，当它非常剧烈时，我经常尖叫，吓坏了狗。但我早上有起床的理由。”
Let me ask you about the set of poems, which happens after she dies. And you set about writing a set of letters to her. Did you actually write her letters every day after she died?
“让我问你关于那一组诗，发生在去世之后。你开始写信给她。她去世后你真的每天都给她写信吗？”
No. I began-- oh, I found out that Maggie Fisher was pregnant. Maggie was one of Jane's nurses. And the first thought you have is-- everybody does this-- something happens and you think, oh, I can't wait to tell Jane. Uh, I can't do that.
“不。我开始——哦，我发现玛吉·费舍尔怀孕了。玛吉是简的护士之一。你有的第一个念头是——每个人都会这样做——有什么事情发生，你心想，‘哦，我等不及要告诉简了。’额，我做不到。”
And I did what I think probably a lot of people have done. I began to write her letters. And the letter form just took me over. The fact that in the letter I could wander around, I could reminisce, I could look out the window and tell her about the weather. I could tell her about things that she was particularly interested in.
“我做了我想可能很多人都做过的事。我开始给她写信。书信的形式让我着迷。事实上，在信中我可以随处漫游，我可以回忆，我可以望向窗外告诉她天气。我可以告诉她她特别感兴趣的事情。”
This was the first one, "Letter With No Address."
“这是第一封，《没有地址的信》。”
Your daffodils rose up and collapsed in their yellow bodies on the hillside garden above the bricks you laid out in sand, squatting with pants pegged and face masked like a beekeeper's against the black flies. Buttercups circle the planks of the old wellhead this May, while your silken gardener's body withers or moulds in the Proctor graveyard.
“你的水仙花在砖块上方的山坡花园里升起并坍塌在它们黄色的身体里，你蹲着，裤腿扎着，脸戴着口罩，像养蜂人一样抵御黑蝇。五月的这时，毛茛花绕着古老井口的木板盘旋，而你丝绸般的园丁身体正在普罗克特墓地枯萎或发霉。”
I drive and talk to you crying, then come back to this house to talk to your photographs. There's news to tell you. Maggie Fisher's pregnant. I carried myself like an egg at Abigail's birthday party a week after you died, as three-year-olds bounced uproarious on a mattress.
“我开车哭着跟你说话，然后回到这所房子对着你的照片说话。有新闻要告诉你。玛吉·费舍尔怀孕了。你去世一周后，在阿比盖尔的生日聚会上，我像个鸡蛋一样小心翼翼，三岁的孩子们在床垫上喧闹地蹦跳着。”
Joyce and I met for lunch at the mall and strolled weepily through Sears and B. Dalton. Today it's four weeks since you lay on our painted bed and I closed your eyes. Yesterday I cut irises to set in a pitcher on your grave. Today I brought a carafe to fill it with fresh water.
“乔伊斯和我在购物中心吃午饭，泪流满面地在西尔斯和B. Dalton逛着。今天是你躺在我们漆过的床上、我合上你双眼已经四周了。昨天我割下鸢尾花放在你墓地的水罐里。今天我带了一个水瓶来装满新鲜的水。”
I remember bone pain, vomiting, and delirium. I remember pond afternoons. My routine is established. Coffee, The Globe , breakfast, writing you this letter at my desk. When I go to bed to sleep after baseball, Gus follows me into the bedroom as he used to follow us. Most of the time he flops down in the parlor, with his head on his paws.
“我记得骨痛、呕吐和谵妄。我记得池塘边的下午。我的例行程序已经建立。咖啡、《环球报》、早餐，在我的书桌前写这封信。棒球赛后我上床睡觉时，格斯像过去跟随我们一样跟着我走进卧室。大部分时间它瘫在客厅里，把头放在爪子上。”
Once a week I drive to Tilton to see Dick and Nan. Nan doesn't understand much, but she knows you're dead. I feel her fretting. The tone of Dick and me talking seems to console her. You know now whether the soul survives death or you don't. When you were dying, you said you didn't fear punishment. We never dared to speak of paradise.
“每周我开车去蒂尔顿看迪克和南。南不太理解，但她知道你死了。我感到她忧心忡忡。迪克和我的谈话语气似乎安慰了她。你现在知道灵魂是否在死亡中存活与否了。当你临终时，你说你不怕惩罚。我们从不敢谈论天堂。”
At 5:00 AM when I walk outside, mist lies thick on the hay fields. By 8:00 the air is clear, cool, sunny with the pale yellow light of mid May. Kearsarge rises huge and distinct, each birch and balsam visible. To the west the waters of Eagle Pond waver and flash through popples just leafing out.
“凌晨5点当我在外面走时，雾气笼罩着干草地。到了8点空气清澈、凉爽、阳光明媚，带着五月中旬苍黄的光。基尔萨奇山巨大而清晰，每一棵桦树和香脂树都可见。向西，鹰池的水在刚长出叶子的白杨树间波动闪烁。”
Always the weather, writing its book of the world, returns you to me. Ordinary days were best, when we worked over poems in our separate rooms. I remember watching you gaze out the January window into the garden of snow and ice, your face rapt as you imagined burgundy lilies.
“总是天气，写着它的世界之书，把你带回我身边。平凡的日子最美，那时我们在各自的房间里磨练诗句。我记得看着你凝视着一月的窗外，进入雪与冰的花园，当你想象着酒红色的百合时，你的脸是多么着迷。”
Your presence in this house is almost as enormous and painful as your absence. Driving home from Tilton, I remember how you cherished that vista with its center the red door of a farmhouse against green fields.
“你在这所房子里的存在感几乎和你缺席的一样巨大和痛苦。从蒂尔顿开车回家，我记得你是多么珍视那片景观，中心是一个农舍的红门，对着绿色的田野。”
Are you past pity? If you have consciousness now, if something I can call "you" has something like consciousness, I doubt you remember the last days. I lift your wasted body onto the commode, your arms looped around my neck, aiming your bony bottom so that it will not bruise on a rail. Faintly, you repeat, Momma, Momma.
“你超越了怜悯吗？如果你现在有意识，如果你能称为‘你’的东西有类似意识的东西，我怀疑你是否还记得最后的日子。我把你瘦弱的身体抬到马桶上，你的手臂勾着我的脖子，对准你骨感的屁股，以免它被轨道弄伤。你微弱地重复着：‘妈妈，妈妈。’”
You lay astonishing in the long box while Alice Ling prayed and sang "Amazing Grace" a capella. Three times today I drove to your grave. Sometimes coming back home to our circular driveway, I imagine you've returned before me, bags of groceries upright in the back of the Saab, its trunk lid delicately raised, as if proposing an encounter, dog fashion, with the Honda.
“你躺在那长长的盒子里，美得惊人，而爱丽丝·凌祈祷并无伴奏唱着《奇异恩典》。今天我三次开车到你的坟前。有时回到我们环形的私家车道，我想象你已经在我前面回来，杂货袋竖立在萨博车的后部，后备箱盖优雅地抬起，仿佛在提议一次狗式的邂逅，带着那辆本田。”
That's like one of my favorite points in all the poem.
“那是我整首诗中最喜欢的点之一。”
Good, good. She would have howled, she would have howled. I mean, that's, you know, I'm really addressing her sort of, when I make a joke like that. She would have loved it.
“很好，很好。她会嚎叫的，她会嚎叫的。我的意思是，那是个，你知道，当我开这种玩笑时，我是在对她说话。她会喜欢这个的。”
Do you find that you're still writing her letters, writing her poems as letters even now?
“你发现即使到现在，你还在给她写信，还在写给她的诗作为信吗？”
I'm writing-- actually what happened after this, still I've continued to write a lot about Jane, but I'm no longer addressing "you." I'm talking about Jane and "her" and "she." She has receded. This is horrible and inevitable and necessary. I can't talk to her in the second person anymore.
“我在写——实际上这之后发生了什么，我依然继续写了很多关于简的事情，但我不再针对‘你’了。我在谈论简和‘她’。她已经退场。这是可怕的，也是不可避免的，更是必要的。我不能再用第二人称跟她说话了。”
Donald Hall. His book of poems about his wife Jane Kenyon is called Without.
唐纳德·霍尔。他写给妻子简·凯尼恩的诗集叫《缺失》。
Man. Our program produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior editor for this show Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Day. Special thanks today to New Hampshire Public Radio. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
伙计。我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克。本节目的高级编辑是保罗·塔夫。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自雷切尔·戴。特别感谢今天的新罕布什尔公共广播电台。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who told me this week it's OK if I have coffee with other program directors. He said it's OK if I can't get other program directors out of my mind.
WBEZ管理层监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他这周告诉我，我可以和其他项目主管一起喝咖啡。他说如果我脑子里挥之不去其他项目主管，也没关系。
He was amazing. He put his arms around me and he just held me. And he said to me, oh, honey, I'm so sorry I can't do that for you anymore.
“他太棒了。他搂住我，只是抱着我。他说：‘哦，亲爱的，我很难过，我不能再为你做那种事了。’”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。